been working on a very different movie
lately haven't you cool hat shoot three
how's that been going
it was great we're about 3/4 of the way
through it
the first two were very successful
especially in the US hence the third one
and and they've really sort of I don't
want to say they've decided to go in a
completely different direction but they
they've added another element and I I'm
sworn to secrecy I can't really say too
much about it they've added sort of like
another genre to it it's like you know
like it's a horror cop now it's a horror
comedy and blank film so which is really
interesting in it and it really puts a
nice spin on it so it's very very
exciting to shoot that did it down in
New Orleans just did three weeks down
there in the swamps and looks fantastic
did you get a lot of bug bites while
you're there do you know don't even talk
to say the word bug bite to me because
when you're down in the bayou
there is no mosquito or insect repellent
that works you can put it all on and
they just they don't care they're like
we don't care bite we don't care
they just go right through it so so
luckily for me I play I can tell you I
play sheriff in it so I was wearing you
know the only part of my body that was
exposed were my hands but at the end of
the day I had bug bites on my palms I've
never been bitten up on my palm before I
had about five or six mosquito bites on
the palms of my hands cuz they're like
we'll take any piece of flesh we can get
so it was crazy you know you're down
there in the in the Bayou and you're
talking alligators you're talking wild
boar you're talking armadillos you're
talking possums nutria which is like a
giant rat I mean it's you're in the
you're in the Bayou so it's it's crazy
you shooting at night and you take your
like camera phone you have like a flash
on your camera you shine it into the
trees it's just a bunch of eyes looking
back at you you're like I don't know
about this I'm heading back to the
trailer have you finished on that now
three more she thinks it's the the the
swamp sequence thank goodness and now
I'm doing a week of exteriors starting
July 30th so yeah and then we'll pretty
should be done and what's after that for
you I teach acting at New York
University so I'll probably go back to
that for the fall semester what's
interesting is there are basically two
kinds of students the ones who walk in
and they know some of the stuff I've
done and they're terrified and think I'm
going to bite them so they're incredibly
quiet and the first time they get up and
do a monologue in front of me they're
trembling you know and then there's the
other type of student has no idea at all
they just think I'm just this you know
I'm just a guy who's like a teacher and
halfway to 2/3 of the way through the
semester they walk in and they go oh my
god so-and-so just told me that you were
in so-and-so I'm freaking out man you
know so I get I got that kind of student
too and then they start thinking about
what they've done and what they've said
and they get all embarrassed and
everything about that it's cool it's fun
it's fun kids are great you know what I
mean
you